- [Narrator] This
program is a presentation
of UCTV for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(mellow electronic music)
- I'm William Lester,
professor of chemistry
and Chair of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
We're pleased, along with
the Graduate Council,
to present Professor Chikashi
Toyoshima, this year's speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock Lecture Series.
As a condition of this bequest,
we're obligated and happy to tell you how
the endowment came to UC Berkeley.
It's a story that
exemplifies the many ways
this campus is linked to the history
of California and the Bay Area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock, a
physician for the Army,
came to San Francisco
during the Gold Rush,
where he opened a
thriving private practice.
In 1885, Charles
established a professorship
here at Berkeley as an expression of
his long-held interest in education.
His daughter, Lily Hitchcock Coit,
still treasured in San Francisco
for her colorful personality
as well as her generosity,
greatly expanded her
father's original gift
to establish a professorship
at UC Berkeley,
making it possible for us to
present a series of lectures.
The Hitchcock fund has become
one of the most cherished
endowments of the
University of California,
recognizing the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
Thank you, Lily and
Charles, and now a few words
about Professor Chikashi Toyoshima.
Chikashi Toyoshima is a
distinguished biophysicist,
and professor at the Institute
of Molecular and Cellular
Bio-sciences at the
University of Tokyo in Japan.
He started his scientific career
as an electron microscopist
and worked on muscle
filaments and iron channels.
Drawing on his expertise in the fields
of mathematics, physics, and biology,
Toyoshima has revealed
the atomic structures
of biological samples that
could never be studied before.
Using x-ray crystallography,
he has determined the structure
of the calcium ATPase,
commonly referred to as the calcium pump,
and different phases of
the energy coupling cycle.
Toyoshima's work on such
biological structures
has revolutionized how
researchers are able
to study the structure of proteins.
Toyoshima is the author
of numerous articles
in scholarly journals.
His research on the calcium
ATPase, which began in 1989,
produced the first images of an ion pump
at work in atomic detail, and explained
why the structure has to be so.
These images graced the cover of Nature,
as well as served as an image
for the journal's annual calendar.
Chikashi Toyoshima was
born in Akita, Japan,
where at a young age, his studies sparked
an interest in the sciences.
He was accepted to the
University of Tokyo in 1973
in the physics department.
And in 1978, chose to pursue biophysics,
receiving his Masters in 1980,
and his doctorate in 1983.
After completing his degree,
Toyoshima served as a research associate
at the University of
Tokyo from 1984 to 1986,
as a postdoctoral Fellow
at Stanford University
from 1986 to 1988.
On a scientific staff the
Medical Research Counsel
Laboratory of Molecular Biology
at Cambridge from 1988 to 1989,
and as a research scientist
at the Frontier Research
Project RIKEN in 1989.
In 1994, he accepted a professorship
at the University of Tokyo.
In 2005, Toyoshima was
elected as a foreign associate
to the National Academy of Sciences.
And in 2006, he was
named a national lecturer
at the Biophysical Society's
51st Annual Meeting,
the Society's highest honor.
Please join me in welcoming
Professor Chikashi Toyoshima.
(applause)
- Well, first of all, I'd like
to thank Hitchcock Committee
and particularly Professor Esther
for a very kind introduction.
But I'd like to tell you
about just one protein.
And this one you are looking here.
And I'd like to tell you how this protein
called calcium pump really works,
and why structure has to be so.
But before going into details,
perhaps I have to introduce
for many nonspecialist
why this protein is important,
and why the calcium is important.
Perhaps many of you here knows that a cell
is full of membrane compartments.
And this is just a cartoon,
but you see in the microcurve
and it's really full of
membrane compartments.
Such biological membrane
consist of lipid bilayers.
And lipid bilayer, it's of
course consist of phospholipids,
and phospholipids has a polar head group
and hydrophobic tails called acid chains.
And they form this kind of membrane sheet.
And so the driving force
is hydrophobic interaction.
And what is good about this
is it self-assembles in water.
And quite extensive one it can make.
And also, it dislike the hole is made,
so it's self-sealing as well.
So it's kind of a super glue in a way.
And it turns out to be
just really the super glue,
and perhaps I'll show you
in the later of my talk.
And the property of this one
is that it is very impermeant to ions,
for example, sodium,
potassium, chloride is here.
It's much more impermeant compared to
water itself, pure water.
And the result is you can
make a concentration gradient
for many ions important
for biological systems.
And the common one is
sodium, for example, sodium.
This is a case of muscle cells,
and I show you how the
muscle cell means that.
But here, the sodium
concentration outside of the cell
is 110 millimolar, and the sodium inside
of the cell is 10 millimolar.
The potassium is opposite.
So you see the tenfold or so
differences in concentration.
But actually, the largest
concentration gradient
you see here is for calcium.
It has more than 10,000
fold gradient here.
And it's not actually rated,
this is divalent cations.
You see the magnesium here.
And magnesium is just same,
inside and outside of the cell.
And what is important is this
ion concentration gradients
are used for many purposes
in biological processes.
They are certainly not in equilibrium.
And equilibrium means
it's, you are dead, right?
Why the calcium is so
important, explained here.
Calcium is actually the
ion that's most widely used
in regulation of cellular processes.
And if you hear the word calcium,
perhaps you think of your bones or teeth.
And it's certainly true
because most of the calcium
in your body is in your
(clears throat) bone and teeth.
One human body contains
about 1400 grams of calcium.
But only 10 grams or
less, so it's less than 1%
is used for regulation
of cellular processes.
So, it looks like very small amount,
but it has very important functions.
And the human body has so
many calcium-binding proteins.
It's a good thing,
I don't want to sort of
tell you about the diversity
of calcium seeing as there are
many excellent reviews here.
So I just want to show
you just one example.
It's a muscle contraction.
You see here your arm muscle, it is,
Muscle is a hierarchical structure.
So, it's actually a
bundle of muscle fibers.
It's called muscle cells.
And muscle fiber itself is consist of
mainly the bundle muscles.
Thick and thin filaments
assembly called myofibril
surrounded by a secure system called
sarcoplasmic reticulum
here, so you see here,
this bundle is called myofibril
it's actually consists of
thick and thin filaments
and it is surrounded by vesicular system,
sarcoplasmic reticulum
and sarcoplasmic reticulum
is a store of the calcium.
And we also see, so
this is a cross-section
of this one, so the sarcoplasmic
reticulum is this things,
and you see this is
actually a vesicular system,
and also the muscle system has the tubal,
called transversal tube,
T-tubule here, right.
And when your brain sort of make order
with muscle to contract, then your muscle
then your motor neuron excites.
The neuron excites, then
the action potential
is emitted and created
and goes down to the muscle
fiber along this nerve fiber.
But what happens here is like this.
Your neuron excites first
at the sodium channel.
The channel for the
sodium ions sort of opens
and then the carbon potassium ions,
potassium channels open
and turns out to make
this kind of action potential.
So the initial stage is electrical signal
So the electrical signals come down
to this synapse and synaptic end
then here voltage dependent,
so-called voltage dependent
calcium channels exist
and make a fusion of this
kind of vesicle also.
This vesicles contain
the chemical substance
so-called acetylcholine.
And acetylcholine is
emitted here like this,
and so this is a chemical signal here.
And chemical signal, so
the acetylcholine binds to
its receptor on the other side
of these synaptic junctions.
And again, it's so that
acetylcholine receptor
is an ion channel, so
it's pass through the ions
sodium ions now can enter this area
and forms the action potential again.
So the electric signal comes here,
then the channel opens, and
the receptor ion channel opens
and again it makes electrical signal.
So it's down to this part,
so it's called T-tubule,
and there is a voltage-dependent
calcium channel,
different one here.
And it excites and it's opened
the so-called calcium release
channel on the t-tubule.
So the T-tubule is connected
to sarcoplasmic reticulum
and so the calcium stored
in the sarco reticulum
released into muscle cells.
If the calcium is released it binds to
Troponin C and Troponin C's
a calcium binding protein
and it moves along filaments
protein called tropomyosin.
And tropomyosin sort of prohibits
the binding of myosin heads
and when the calcium are
absent, but when its calcium
come to combine to this protein,
then this Tropomyosin moves and allows
this myosin head to move
productive interactions.
Then the force is made, and
happens this kind of movement.
So the key here is the calcium.
As I told you that here
is the calcium channel,
the sodium ion channels, and
the calcium channel again,
and the other calcium channel.
So there are many kind of
different kind of ions
actually used for excitation.
One thing I try to stress here is
the channel follows
concentration gradient.
So it's a diffusion process.
And no energy is actually
required so it's very efficient.
More than 10 million ions per second
can go through a second.
It's a very efficient system.
We learned that calcium
is a very important ion,
but why is the calcium so useful?
Say why not magnesium?
And the answer is that
actually our systems
our living system,
because has lots of water
and water a really unusual substance
and so let's think about
what kind of properties
are required for a good
ion for degradation.
So the good ion here means
that a good ions easily
pass through and can invigorate
the biological processes.
So, speed is certainly important,
if you want to make the
processing and the degradation
fast enough, of course the
ions have to pass through
the ion channels quite quickly.
And if the ions bind to many proteins,
it does not help for degradation,
so it has to have a very
good specificity, right.
But also, if you don't need many ions,
that will of course help.
Because just a small amount
of change is good enough
for degrading your biological processes.
Then, the next question, so
I can sort of think of these
three parameters, then
the next question asks
in which physical property does
determine these parameters?
Size of the ion, or the charges of ions?
Or something more exotic?
Well the answer is both charges and size.
So the size of cells,
of course we have a lot,
all the substances immersed in water.
And water is, I mentioned
that is an unusual substance.
Because it has a strong polarizability.
Polarizability means as a whole,
this is a neutral molecule,
it has a charge, it's a
partial charge on oxygen,
tends to be negative and hydrogen
tend to be a bit positive.
When you look at the sodium
chloride, that's the salt,
when you dissolve it in the water,
it's not just separated
like independent ions,
it's actually surrounded
by water molecules,
and sodium ion has a positive charge so
the negative charge of
oxygen sort of attracted to,
attracted and aligned water
molecules to like this way.
And for the negative ions,
charges chloride ions,
the water surrounds like this.
We are living in 300k
or something like that,
so there are lots of thermal
movement or thermal agitations.
So this so-called hydration sphere,
or hydration shell, is
a great dynamic one.
Compare the size of the ions
to water molecules here.
Lithium is just a .6 or so on the nucleus,
and the biggest one I show here
is Titanium at 1.4 hydration
and in the water environment
it's surrounded like this.
I just show you one
sort of hydration shell,
it's called primary hydration shell.
But it's actually surrounded
by second hydration shell,
and even more sort of water molecules.
So that means that the ions are completely
wrapped around by water molecules, right.
So, for the proteins to
be able to distinguish
which one, which ion, the
protein actually needs,
it has to sort of remove the water atoms,
water molecules from ions,
so it has to be partially
removed, partially dehydrated,
for the protein to be able to reorganize.
So then the exchange actual
process is sort of like this.
In the water, there was this
sodium ion surrounded by
many water molecules, but
it's a dynamic of things,
there's a chance for this sodium
ion to lose water molecule,
and then the protein, our oxygen atoms,
so the substitute, this water oxygen atom,
to make this kind of interactions,
and so then protein
actually touches this ion.
Then if the ions, if pass
through this very narrow part
then it will rehydrate again.
That means the water binds again.
So for the efficient transfer,
these sodium ions should
not notice whether this ion
is in the water molecule,
in the water environment
or it's touching the proteins.
So for what that means is like this.
So this is an actual structure
of a potassium channel.
Solved by MacKinnon almost
nearly 10 years ago or so,
and this is a view along
the membrane plane.
So this just a lateral
view of the membrane.
This is called helices,
and the narrow body's here.
This shows the two potassium ions.
So the potassium ions come from this way
and get out like that.
And if you look in more detail,
the potassium ions in this narrow area,
have an oxygen atom
coordinating like this,
so the protein atoms make coordination.
Very much the same as the
potassium ions in water.
So the potassium ion do not know whether
it's in the water or in the
another part of proteins.
So the key thing is that...
protein oxygen atom can
substitute the water molecule.
For to discriminate sodium, sorry,
the potassium from sodium,
it uses the difference
in hydration energies,
so that means that a chance for
this ion to lose water molecules.
Also if you put sodium
ion in this channel,
it looks like this, so this
is a view from the top.
Because this has four subunits,
this another part can actually
has actually four oxygen
atoms, this shows just, yeah.
So these four atoms.
So in this potassium channel,
it has a perfect golden ration geometry.
Just as in the potassium ion is in water,
and the sodium ion cannot fit so well,
and because it is smaller.
The sodium ion is much
smaller than potassium ions.
The sodium ion cannot go through
because of difference in hydration energy
and difference in the
coordination geometry
and I used the words
hydration energy here,
but I did not explain well.
So this is sort of the
definition of hydration energy.
So the hydration energies
change when one mole of molecule
is transferred from gas
phase to aqueous phase.
Here is that sort of numbers.
And so then I compare the lithium,
sodium and potassium and also
magnesium and calcium here.
So there are clear differences.
Although the sodium is....
30% or so smaller, the hydration energy
is also 15 kilocalories or so different.
And this number is
actually very large number.
I will explain it later in my talk.
And if you compare this
number to a divalent cations,
the difference is so large, right.
So this energy means that
if this number is larger,
the chances for water molecule
to detach from this ions becomes smaller.
So this is so-called
water substitution rate.
So this one, this is
methane ion to look at here.
And so the substitution
rate means water molecule
in the back has already made the exchange
of this unbound water molecules.
So you see the sodium,
potassium, lithium here, right.
Following the numbers given
in the previous table,
the potassium has the highest
substitution number, rate.
And sodium's slower, smaller and slower,
and the lithium is more slower.
What is interesting is
calcium and magnesium.
Calcium is similar to sodium.
So, it has a 10 to the 8th rate constant.
But magnesium has a much
slower rate constant.
It has a 10 to the 5th or so.
So it's clear that it cannot be used
for microsecond degradations.
So it has much longer time for
getting through the channel.
But calcium is quite
similar to monovalent ions.
It's very fast.
So the calcium can be
used for transmitting
single ion by using channels.
And the magnesium is
much slower, so it needs,
perhaps needs special
system, not simple channel
is not good enough for magnesium transfer.
And certainly there are several
magnesium transporters I know of,
and they are transporters
and they use same energies
and not merely a simple channel
using the thermal energies.
Let's think about this
specificities, here.
I compare the magnesium, calcium,
and the coordination by oxygen atoms.
So this picture is written in scale.
So this is actual, you can
consider this as actual size
of the magnesium and oxygen,
the size of the oxygen.
So around magnesium you can certainly,
there's four oxygen
atoms and two on behind
and on top of this magnesium.
So the six coordination is quite possible,
and has a very nice geometry.
For the calcium, it's not impossible,
but some distance is still,
some spaces are available and
you can actually make seven.
Just five oxygen atoms...
completely fill the space
surrounding this calcium ion.
So this, if you can put
one oxygen atom behind
and on top this calcium, so the seven
coordination is quite possible.
And perhaps looks, perhaps
makes a very nice coordination,
will give a high affinity to our system.
But if you look at the
same configuration to,
of magnesium, it's impossible
already because magnesium
is smaller ions, so if we put
five oxygen atoms like this,
it's contact too much,
too hard really, too hard.
It cannot accommodate
this kind of geometry.
And also there must be
a strong attraction,
electrostatic interaction
between oxygen atoms,
because it becomes too close.
We know, how do you know it is...
If the atom is small,
if the ion is smaller,
then the distance between this middle ion
and the coordinating
oxygen atom is shorter.
That means that the electrostatic
force will be stronger.
That also means that
this binding is tighter.
But because of the smallness of this ion,
it requires a quite regular geometry
of coordinating oxygen atoms.
And here, if it becomes bigger than
the seven coordination possible,
so if the protein has several
oxygen atoms like this,
it only selects the calcium,
and magnesium cannot bind.
So it converts the protein specificities.
So the big ion like calcium
is just really, pretty good.
In reality, this is an atomic model of a
one calcium binding
protein called subtilisin,
it has seven coordination
and this is the most
common calcium binding motif, actually.
And it always has seven
coordinating oxygen atoms.
This can exclude magnesium
binding very well.
So I can sort of list four
reasons that make calcium ideal
for regulation of cellular processes.
It's a divalent cations,
it's free to monovalent
the affinity could be
too low and you may need
a big number of ions have to be
transferred to regulate the processes.
And it's large enough.
Because it's large enough, it has,
it can give the protein specificity
to exclude sodium ions,
sorry the magnesium.
And it is a so-called hard ion.
Hard metal ion, so it likes
oxygen for coordinations.
On some ions...
like gold, likes sulfur atoms,
and the protein is mostly consists
of carbon, oxygen, nitrogen,
and the content of the sodium,
the sulfur atom is much smaller.
So it makes sense to use abundant
oxygen atoms for coordinations.
All these properties are
apply to say strontium,
it is even bigger and has divalent ions.
And like oxygen for coordination.
But you cannot find much, large amounts
of strontium in the nature.
So you can't really rely on it.
So these four reasons make calcium so good
for the regulation of processes.
Instead, magnesium has
a, it requires very...
regular geometry for binding.
And has a stronger power
for fixing the oxygen atoms.
So that means magnesium can be used
for fixing protein structure.
Even for catalyzing reaction
by pulling electrons
towards magnesium, because
it has a much stronger power
compared to calcium.
One more thing I have to try to mention,
a very low concentration
of calcium inside the cell.
This perhaps in evolution,
this was necessary,
because otherwise calcium, if
it's higher and the calcium
precipitated phosphorate,
massive amounts abundant
in interior of the cells.
But what is good about this
is because it's so low,
only a very small number
transfer from outside to inside.
Then, it's a big change.
That's also pretty good for
the sensitivity of the system.
It's very efficient because it doesn't
have to transfer so many ions.
So many sort of good things about calcium.
And this (clears throat) difference is in
ion concentration used for signaling,
as I mentioned, as I explained
using muscle systems,
and that purpose is the channels I used,
plus very efficient system,
10 million ions per second.
But, if the system has to go
back to the original position
otherwise you can make
just one contraction,
it makes no sense.
So what is very important is
to make these sort of stable
conditions shown in the
slide and that is maintained
by so-called ion pumps
and so the ion pumps
works against concentration gradient
because after the excitation,
the calcium sort of released
from the sarcoplasmic
reticulum to muscle cells.
But it has to be pumped back
into the sarcoplasmic reticulum.
So this process occurs against
concentration gradient,
so it requires energy.
And the, as I mentioned, as I
explained using this shortly,
it requires the ATP and so it's,
it uses the energy of ATP,
it goes through cycles.
The cycle is only 30 cycles
possible at normal temp,
for your body temperatures
and one cycle can
transfer only two calcium ions.
So altogether, only 60 calcium ions
per second actually transferred.
So if you compare these two
numbers, it's a huge difference.
So if these, the nature
wants to make the contraction
and the relaxation in
a similar time scale,
you need a very small number of ions,
but you need huge number of pumps, right.
If I were to explain this to you.
So if the ion pumps concentration
gradient are maintained
by ion pump, it's a real name,
it's more sort of a rigorous
name is a P-type ATP,
it's the energy comes from this reactions.
So the, adenosine triphosphate
so the arm of a beta gamma phosphate,
the adenosine model is here
is hydrolyzed so this beta gamma
phosphate born is cut here,
and makes a phosphate.
But in the real system is actually this
gamma phosphate is transferred
to the protein first.
This process is called phosphorylation.
What else I should mention is that
about 25% of ATP is consumed
is used for ion pumping.
So maintaining the ion
concentration gradient.
And the number of ATP,
amount of ATP consumed
is nearly your body weight.
And it's a very large number.
But so, perhaps you have
heard that the life's energy
currency, the ATP, and all living things
having to use the ATP
for energy conversion.
And actually the Nobel
Prize in chemistry 1997...
have been given to people
who studied the ATPase
and the ATP synthesis.
But the energy liberated by
ATP hydrolysis is rather small.
And under normal certain
conditions it's about
12 kilocalories per mole, if
you remember the hydration
energy of calcium, it's
360 kilocalorie per mole.
If you compare it is 30 times hire, right.
So it seems that, it looks
like very small number.
And if you, and we know that
this number corresponds
to approximately 20 times
higher than the thermal energy.
So all the system is sort
of shaking by thermal energy
and that thermal energy is
about 6 kilocalorie per mole.
But if you compare this
number with only 20 times,
so the amount of energy...
hydrogen diversify ATP hydrolysis
looks kinda small and so,
what we could do (clears throat)
what the ATP does is seems can,
not much, but is actually,
the efficiency is so high
I will show you later.
Yeah, so this is a point I
want to make a few minutes ago.
So you can actually count
calcium channels here.
I mentioned that the number of channels
required is very small.
And actually, you can
count in the micrograph.
But you need huge number
of pump molecules.
And this is a scallop muscle,
so a scallop has a very
good, thick muscle fiber.
And in the Scallop muscle,
this micrograph shows that
array of pump molecules.
Pump protein, so this eye
shows you just one unit here.
All of these are pump proteins.
There are so many, and
actually more than 60%
or 70% of all the membrane
from the proteins residing
in the membrane actually occupied
by this calcium pump proteins.
So it's quite good for structural studies.
And in structure study,
we have to make crystals
so this is a kind of
very short explanation.
We have a kind of this vesicle system
grown from an actual rabbit muscle,
so it's proteins at the beginning
is residing in the membrane.
So the membrane is dissolved
by adding detergent
so the detergent now sort of substitutes
the phospholipids' here access.
There are two ways, and
using using detergent only,
you may be able to make
crystal like this one.
It's completely different from
the original alignment in the membrane.
But, what we do is adding...
what you would call phosphatidyl choline.
Phosphatidyl choline is a sort of major
phospholipid in the membrane.
And make a kind of
reconstitution like this one.
And at the beginning or in
the history of a membrane
protein crystallization,
this is the one first made by
Michel and he got the Nobel
Prize and he mentioned
that this one is not very good because
you cannot make large enough crystals.
But so nobody actually succeeded
in making good crystals
of calcium ATPase as in pump proteins,
but we have managed to make
crystals by sort of adding the
phospholipid and kind of
making kind of reconstitution.
So this is a crystal of a calcium ATPase.
Calcium pump proteins.
And this is a cross-section made by...
electron microscopy.
And you see the scale is one micrometer.
And if you look at the
edge of the crystal,
you see the bilayers sort of stick out,
and make a funny loops.
And even funnier ones here.
You see the end of the
crystals the lipid barrier
can cause this like that.
And clearly shows that our crystal
rarely have membrane like environment.
So we consider that the crystal,
the proteins in the crystal maintain
this sort of native
conditions, native structures.
So the actual picture of
the pump protein, like this.
So this is so-called
CPK or space fill model,
so they each, they are after
the structure determination,
we determine to coordinate
of all the heavy atoms,
heavy atoms means that they
are heavier than the carbon atoms.
So if you represent each atom
with its (mumbles) perhaps,
Then you can make sort of
most accurate in terms of
the space or volume, like this one.
But you don't see any sort
of chemical bond here.
You don't know how this
model and the amino acids
are interacting at all.
So then, once sort of...
One level of abstraction is using
so-called ball and stick model.
So now, each atom is presented
by single ball but the size
is much smaller than the actual size.
But we can show the chemical
bond, covalent bond by sticks.
So you see the spaces
here if you consider that
actual protein is full of spaces
or vacuum, that's not true.
Its real shape is like this,
but to understand the protein
structure we use this
kind of abstractions.
And still, we don't see
the structure so easily.
The next abstraction is using
the so-called secondary structure.
It's a kind of building block of proteins.
And this spirals called
alpha-helix and sort of kind,
It's sort of a...
considered kind of cylinders.
And here you see the
kind of ribbons, sorry,
arrows like this one, this one is called
beta-sheet and so it's
the protein structure,
you can consider that, the
proteins consists of sheets
and cylinders and
connecting groups, right.
So this is perhaps the easiest way to...
represent the actual protein structures.
Let's think about how the pumps the
calcium ATPase should look like.
And we know that this is ATP powered pump,
and the sum calculation I didn't show,
but it's effect the energy usage
is almost about 100% efficient.
And it must have a specific specificity
because it's a calcium pump,
it should not pump sodium,
for example, or potassium, and
so it must have a mechanism
for rejecting sodium and other ions.
And it needs two gates,
I'll explain here soon.
It must be cytoplasmic and
this is called lumenal gate,
lumen because this is a vesicular system
and inside of the vesicle is called lumen.
So cytoplasmic and lumen gate must exist
somewhere here, right.
The chemical reaction reaction should
take place somewhere in the cytoplasm
because ATP cannot go through
the transmembrane path,
because it's a highly charged molecule.
So, somewhere in this cytoplasmic region,
the chemical reaction should take place.
That chemical reaction
has to be transferred
or transmitted to a gating
system somewhere in the membrane.
So and my point is the structure
should explain these things
by and I go back to these gate things.
If, because this pump should work against
concentration gradient
if it has only one gate,
then there's a chance
it's when this gate opens
if the other gate is open,
then the some ions can go,
should be able to go through
and following the concentration gradient.
That should not happen, right.
To prevent that, we at
least need another gate
so we must have a two-gate system.
Conventionally, the
pump action is explained
by this type E1/E2 theory
of calcium transport,
and the E1 form, the
cytoplasm gate is open,
and the calcium can get
in to transmembrane gate,
transmembrane calcium binding site.
The calcium binding site
must have a higher affinity
and if one finds ATP bind here,
it must be allowed to split
into phosphate and ATP
and this phosphate is transferred
from ATP to a protein cell.
And during this process, this gate,
cytoplasm gate, becomes closed.
It forms a so-called ground state.
And this way the ATP triggers
the change of the structure
and the other side of the gate will open,
that's called lumenal gate opens.
Then the calcium will
be released like this.
This by release of this
phosphate, so in this case,
hydrolysis of phosphorate,
actually aqueous phosphate.
And there is a phosphate release
and the lumenal gate closes, right.
Then the sort of automated isomerization
of structure change, actually
perhaps triggered by protons
and find the calcium released.
There are lots of protons
inside the lumenal area
and the proton can get
into this binding site and
sort of neutralize the charge
imbalance created by calcium.
But we know that neutral pH
these protons are released
and make this calcium
binding site higher affinity.
So this is a cycle and
classically you want this form
which has a higher affinity
and open to cytoplasm.
And it is true to some extent,
but there is a position
which has a state in which
both gates are closed.
So we can't say there is the E1 state
is open to the cytoplasm.
Perhaps the correct definition,
the E1 has a, the E1 form is a higher
affinity form for calcium.
And the E2 form is the same.
The classical definition
of E2, and if you look
at the textbook, E2 form
is mainly defined as
low affinity to calcium but open to lumen.
It is true, but only in this state.
In other E2 state is closed.
So, new definition perhaps
the most accurate definition
is E2 form is has a low
affinity to calcium.
I hope you don't sort of get confused.
Anyway, the key thing is here, this end
in this cycle, the two
gates sort of regulated
No state in this reaction
cycle, both gates are open.
So, in this state, both gates are closed,
and the other state, the only
one state one gate are closed.
And the actual pumping
process is done by changing
the affinity of binding site
from high affinity to low affinity.
So I hope I can make
structure sort of explanation
for this (mumbles)...
this is a kind of appetizer
for tomorrow's talk
and by making crystals of many
sort of intermediate states
you can make this kind of movies.
This movie actually made from
seven crystal structures.
And then there's an intermediate
states are generally
devised of simple interpolation so it's,
I don't say this is an accurate movement,
but it gives you lots of insight into how
the pumps here works.
From these things we can ask why the
movement you saw here is
so large and I'll show you
the top of things the calcium's purpose,
the calciums bind to
binding site and or get out.
And the ATP comes out and
so for the calcium to get
in here, and get out soon.
Helices and the gate closes access,
but just to see the movement
so large and complicated.
And why such large and complicated
domain movements are necessary?
And we know that is related
to chemical reaction rate,
ATPate Hydrolysis.
What does ATP do?
And as I mentioned before,
the hydrolysis of ATP
occurs, it's the gamma
phosphate is transferred to
proteins so it's
so-called phosphorylation.
So what does phosphorylation do?
Why is phosphorus
necessary, or when the final
overall reaction is just ATP hydrolysis?
I think I should stop here today.
Thank you very much for your attention.
(applause)
- [Guest] Thank you for a
very interesting lecture,
I had a question, I came
in a bit late so maybe
you answered it already, but I'm not sure.
In neuroscience, it's very
helpful to use calcium
images to look at what's
happening in active
nervous systems, and the
time scale of the calcium
images is much longer than
the millisecond time scale
of the action potentials,
so I was wondering
if you could say what determines
the time scale in this case?
Is it the entrance of
calcium or what mechanism?
- Well, so that depends on the
interaction with the fluorescent dye.
it's a curator of calcium,
and the affinity is much
higher usually than to water molecule.
And what I mentioned is
the substitution rate of
water molecules and in the
water molecules detach in the,
well I got back to here.
It's between the nanosecond
to 10 nanosecond range.
But this is in the case
of water molecules.
And it's much different
if you look at sort of
tight binding made by
fluorescent dye curators.
Does that make your question,
answer to your question?
- [Guest] I think in
begins to answer, yes.
So it's a necessary aspect of
connecting to the dye, right?
- Mm-hmm, yes.
- [Guest] And would have
to be very clever to think
of a faster way, I suppose.
- Thanks.
- [Man] There's also a sodium pump,
and if this pump transfers charge,
why do we need two
different kinds of pumps,
a sodium pump and calcium pump?
- Sorry, say it again.
- [Man] Sodium pump is responsible for the
(crosstalk drowns out
speaker) action potential.
- Sodium Potassium, but not Calcium.
- Yes, but what's the distinction?
Why are there two
separate pumping actions,
one for sodium and one for calcium?
It seems you could use one pump for both.
- Well for the specificity you cannot.
Because it has to for
the sodium and calcium,
requires different environment, right.
Okay, so the sodium is a monovalent ion,
the calcium is divalent ions, right.
So in the case of divalent ions
the surrounding oxygen atoms are...
some of the oxygen atom
has negative charges,
and the negative charges should match
the positive charges on the calcium,
so it should match the charge itself.
So the calcium binding site can sort of
cannot have a high affinity to sodium.
It's the same thing applies
for the sodium bond.
So although the size is
different to make high affinity,
to calcium for example, it
cannot be the sodium pump,
because it cannot make
high affinity sodium.
- [Man] Right.
- So it's just a charge
balance in this case.
(applause)
(mellow electronic music)